yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is the book review for the end of
the year 2018 yeah I tried this camera
angle again I did something similar last
year and I hope it's going to work out
fine you see the whole board this time
last year I had to only have over the
board visible but I think it's it's
better that way I can always suck yeah
put the book back yeah and you see what
it is I think it should be a good a good
way to do it for some of the books we
don't even need the bottle that much for
the opening books I think it's quite
useful but for the other ones probably
not so much so let's get going last year
I did a really long video it was I think
almost one hour and it also included
some of the books that weren't even
published in 2017 in this case but some
old favorites that I wanted to present
and I don't have any old favorite this
time what I wanted to include basically
included last year I don't think I've
got anything there so I'm mostly
focusing on new books or I have one book
actually that is a bit older two or
three years maybe I have to check it but
it's one book that I only recently
started to use in my my training so and
I think it's quite good to mention
because it's not very well known and I
think it is quite good anyway we'll get
to that later
first of all before I get to some of the
books I wanted to mention something
about my own products of course because
I had a book released this year as well
a traditional print book that keep it
simple one if one yeah very well known
probably to you to my channel get
regular channel visitors whatever mostly
want to say about it and it's very
nocturne yeah
useful for me to tell you again what is
in and so on but I wanted to what I want
is that that the follow-up basically is
already in the works keep it simple 1.d4
is going to be the next release on
chasuble and later as a print book it's
already in the works so if you are more
of a tea for gaya that's that's one that
you should be looking forward to I'm
shooting for release April May is
something like that so four to five
months maybe cooker maybe longer I mean
I have the concept lined out but it's um
it would be a long way until one deform
is fitted into one book anyway that I
wanted to mention I mentioned it already
in some some other occasions but this is
a good way to announce it I think so
let's get two books by other authors and
this is a lot I I think I'm close to
showing you all the books that I got
this year I think I'm very close to that
I made a conscious effort to buy less
books because I simply don't have the
time to look at all of them and it is
some it's almost a waste of money to buy
like 50 books a year what can you do
with them you cannot read them it's just
not possible so I try to really limit
myself to the ones that I felt were
useful to me were interesting to me and
there's also the other book that was
sent to me for revenue
I mean I think 90% of the books I bought
was hell but there are two or three
India that were sent to me by valuing
Chesham I mean I've published my book
with human shells and they they tend to
send me some of the new books to review
so let's get started I want to mention
two books that are already featured on
my channel but they are amongst the I
think most interesting releases of this
year so I should be mentioned them again
the first one is the woodpecker method
I've had this in the channel on the
channel before when it was released on
chasuble
it is really quality chess and it's
mostly about improving your technical
vision yeah by solving a set of
exercising and a set of exercises over
and over again I think this is a very
interesting method to try to improve
your tactics but I would like to refer
to you to the video already did some
month ago I also think this is a print
book of course but it has his chess over
release and I strongly recommend the
chance of aversion because it is simply
the solving the tactics puzzles is
excellently done online it's just easier
than in a print book and it helps you to
track your progress so the very nice
camp the the second book and this is
probably my favorite book of this year
especially if you think it's always
difficult to compare opening book to a
middle game or general improvement book
so this is the one it's small steps to
join approval by Sam Shanklin it's his
first book and I also made a video on
that already when it was released on
chasuble they had a good discount on
chasuble so it was a good want to point
out it's a really excellent book on
chess strategy I think and it focuses on
pawn plane as you can maybe guess
yeah the small steps are the pawn the
pawn moves and it has a second child a
master pong playing chess
again I don't want to talk about it for
too long I think I made a video on that
already and I don't want to repeat
everything that
said I think it's a really great book
many good examples I also like the
writing style assembles very yeah it's a
very straightforward term is a very very
very straightforward way of expressing a
thought very honest very very clear-cut
and there's also I think very much a
virtue of his writing okay now let's get
to some books that I have not yet
featured on my channel let's go with the
probably most unusual one first and in
some way maybe the most interesting one
because it is not really comparable to
anything else that was released it is
this one it's called another surface by
Jung Marcos Marcos's
Grandmaster from Slovakia Slovakia and
this is a really really out-of-the-box
book it is a really funny cover by the
way if you it's very tough probably to
fake and actually see it quite well on
the video you see it has this picture of
the Titanic going towards an iceberg and
it's yeah it shows that there's one move
above the surface but many moves below
and it's kind of the philosophy of this
book that in chess we often see
something quite simple relatively simple
looking over the board but there are
many many things hidden under the
surface and it is a really tough to
describe book in a way it has many
chapters it has 33 chapters in 2300
almost 300 pages and it has many
different subjects it's more of a
collection of of essays or collection of
single topics then let's say one
monolithic book that wants to convey
certain point it has some certain
strategic points and ideas that
for example I'm going to give you one
example and the second part is called
about the inhabitants of the chessboard
and what he does is he makes a small
chapters of ten pages where he shows a
particular particular feature of pieces
yeah how how bishops move and one one
interesting shape today is about couples
billiard ball so he talks about a cup of
uncanny ability to use as bishops in a
way that they would I can I can show you
that on the board like the bishop would
go here and then like on a billiard
table it would basically go here next so
it kind of it bounces off the side of
the board and then goes this way I know
it sounds really odd but he collected
many examples but Karpov had exactly
this thing in particular on them on the
first rank like Bishop back and then
here or something like that it's is
really quite remarkable and he also has
some some chapters about a statistical
let's same or statistics about openings
like how many minor piece endings do you
get from a particular opening that
sounds really odd but it's kind of
interesting because if you think about
this a little bit there are definitely
differences there in particular when it
comes to things like the bishop pair for
example in some openings you will get
the bishop pair more often than not for
example let's say you're black you play
the Sicilian special ink off that is
what you aim for you would get the
bishop pair a lot because white will
quite often I'm just going to maybe put
first moves on the board if you are in
this very cough and this is a solid
point there white will more often than
not play Bishop g5 and later trade here
so black will get too
should pay a lot if white wants to avoid
this fashion call they actually quite
often if we go go back we'll play the
Rasta limo which also gives you the
bishop air a lot so the black side of
this opening means that if you are a
bishop air fan this is maybe one for you
you get the bishop pay a lot and there
are many other very out-of-the-box ideas
that presents in the book very
interesting topics here are about
computer chess like the development of
chess engines what they were able to do
a while ago what they able to do now and
also quite interesting is one longer
chapter is interview with one of them
maybe the best current correspondence
chess player range shows or explains how
he uses engines what his own
contribution is to his own playing
ability when the engine is obviously
much stronger than he is but he still
has yeah he still has some input to what
happens on the board because he has two
we have filter out things by the engine
that are not that great and so on it's
really quite interesting and the only
thing that is not so clear with this
book is what does it actually help you
does it help you to be a better chespin
maybe but it is that the kind of reading
experience where you think oh that's
interesting I'm not a thought of that
before but it's not I believe a very
very typical trade book that can be used
for training or it doesn't have any
exercises for example it just has many
of those movements I say I'm interesting
yeah and this makes it quite remarkable
it's just very much not like any other
book that you that you usually usually
get so I think it's very interesting and
and
getting mostly I think for stronger
players it won't help
let's say and say that - because 6700
1600 1700 player but if you're let's say
in 2000 and above and you are interested
in out-of-the-box thinking it can be
something for you
this book has one of the unit's chess
Federation's book of the year what a
head of Sam Jenkins book which I kind of
understand because it's so different but
I'd still would prefer Shannon's book
simply because of usability it s it has
exercises and it has things that I think
can be more helpful for the general
player and for wider range of playing
strength I don't see a 1500 ya reading
Marko's book and getting much out of it
I think many of the concepts are just a
little bit too advanced or simply too
much out of the book I mean there's this
famous cautionary Claudia in order to
violate principles you shouldn't you
should know them first and this applies
a little bit to that book yeah it shows
interesting points or but you only
appreciate them as interesting and out
of the box if you know what the box is
sort of saying okay now to something a
little bit more standard let's say and I
think this is a this is a very very
strong recommendation actually if you
are into the market for for those books
or these kind of books it's actually
there two books itself is this one
playing money form what is called
exactly French defense and Sicilian
sidelines is the first one and the
second one is playing before sicilian
main lines so this is by john shaw and
the quality chess team they already made
the playing efore book with mine
Alliance and
that was at the end of 2016 I believe
and now this year and those two books
were released at about the same time in
the summer and so I have written a book
on 1.e4 keep it simple only for my book
has 380 pages or something like that
and they're playing you for books by
show how much do they have 430 let's
chill 350 roughly and so or you know
we've got like two thousand two hundred
pages or something around that maybe two
thousand one so it's a lot bigger if you
want even more like more material you
can go for phone ages books there are
thousands of pages so you have different
level that say of detail and different
level of sophistication those
repertoires my book is called keep it
simple because it is reasonably simple
to learn so for example if you look at
the Sicilian defense yeah I am went for
Bishop b5 Sicilian here and I went for
Bishop b5 check one in case of e six I
went for c3 if you look at Shaw's book
he's got them
this is why it's basically one and a
half books aside he goes for the open
Sicilian oh yeah I think invariably yeah
they never go for they don't go for the
Russell Nimmo anything it just always
the open Sicilian so this is much more
theory and it's much sharper you need to
learn many more lines in case of the
French by the way what I recommend to
exchange variation and
very happy still with this
recommendation they have the tirage
which is basically what I would
recommend if you don't want to play the
exchange and want to be a little more
sophisticated so these books are
excellently researched as are all
quality chess books and they can be
let's say the step up from my book yeah
I would still I mean I've written this
book for four reason but I think it is a
good one but maybe at some point you
want to expand you want to in some cases
sharpen up your repertoire you want
something a little bit a little bit more
that's a tactical and confrontational
and then those books can be exactly this
step that you can take with money form
you don't have so many trans positions
as you have with d4 so it is quite easy
if you say let's say you get those two
books yeah you have the Sicilian you got
the French so let's say you have you
like lines in my book then start like
that you like the Rosso Nemo and you
like them this one but you say you know
this is he three it's not it's not sharp
enough let's expand a little bit and why
not do this so you can in this case keep
parts of my repertoire but adopt some
open Sicilian lines without you learning
or having to learn absolutely everything
for example in this case you would need
something against a six against ninety
six and nine f6 so it's there is no
dragon for example there is no neither
of this no sveshnikov there is no
Kalashnikov whatever so you could in
many cases start with my book and then
expand with those books it's a matter of
taste in also in some cases do you want
to play the open Sicilian or do you want
to play a more strategically focused
line
I think this this set of loops I mean
again there are three folks here the
third one has from 2016 and now they
published the final two ones they can be
an excellent step after having my book
or you can it's your choice you can skip
my book and directly say okay let's go
open Sicilian and so on and if they're
excellent um just adjust but it's very
well researched very well written so
it's kind of them this is the the middle
tier that say II for repertoire book if
you want to go the neji books the
grandmaster repertoire books they are
really close to overkill he's got like
how many books three books on the
Sicilian or four so it's really really
really tough to do that and not really
suitable for amateur I think the the
playing a four by Sean is it is
borderline it is doable but it's it's
already a lot of theory okay so let's
continue so opening do I have I actually
got to only two or three days ago and
that makes no sense it was Christmas
like the day before Christmas or so I
got two books that I cannot review
because I got them and I haven't really
looked at them the queen's indian
defense by Mike Royce and across the
other one added she Corinne Bible yeah
that's a very interesting one by sokolov
and in Salgado Lopez but I have not
really used the books I just gotten them
and like okay nice I have them now but
it didn't really look through them so
it's tough for me to review them already
in particular the children book is of
course interesting because that is
my opening with black or one of my
openings okay the next one the
modernized Hong Kong the book on the
CARICOM yeah by Daniel Hernandez
Hernandez was not known to be ism
Grandmaster I think he's he's British
yeah doesn't sound too British good I
think he is from from the UK and this is
a book published by thinkers publishing
a new publishing company and it's a
pretty nice book I think on the Karo in
particular because it features some
lines they are not as regularly featured
ok let's get going the compound is of
course this one in 46 and the main
choices that black has are actually
against the advance where you need to
make a choice what exactly do you want
to play what set up and in the in the
main line position yeah and what he has
recommended I think is interesting here
basically every book that I know I think
there is one by the Budokan there's one
by by your banker house come and they
they will go here a Bishop f5 the
so-called classical variation and this
book is different and he's recommending
97 line that is often just talked how
does the connotation associated with
smooth Norfolk Karpov do they know he
doesn't she just says 97 relation
okay okay yeah it's usually called snow
snow force muscle of cop or something
like that and 97 is a perfectly playable
line but somehow not interfere not in
fashion and I think this is I think a
good recommendation Bishop f5 I really
think it's not very what I've looked at
this over the years and black basically
has two choices after Bishop f5 you can
Castle short later or long if you Castle
long if you cancel Queen side you're
like eternal is slightly worse and if
you Castle kingside
I mean at least I intended to get
checkmated a lot it's not bad of course
it's not for everyone it was a lot for
me for example so this is a good 197
preparing that f6 it's one cup of plate
most of the time so a good a good line
to cover and what he does also is he
covers in the advance and I think this
is very useful in the advance variation
he covers two lines after Bishop f5
rider 3 the short system he covers we're
talking about this he covers c5 and 97
to main lines and he gives an overview
also which is a little bit less
convincing he he misses one or two
things so it's not not super problematic
and this one the multi courts the ARCA
tanking variation so he gives a black
pretty wide range of choices and I think
this is this is good yeah because the
advance you will get quite often and
knowing more than one line makes a lot
of sense advanced variation is probably
the critical 9 against Carl yeah I like
the book and I like the line selection a
lot because especially 97 is totally
under-covered in Chester Georgia and I
think he does he does a good job yeah
and that's one I like the book I think
this is also unknown on chesil if you
prefer an online version okay
and any book that also cannot tell you
too much about I only and actually good
yeah I also have a son mentioned because
it's also read really fresh here on my
on my shelf but it's this one it's the
tester that's it's difficult to read
right because of well yeah anyway it's
called play d4 d5 c-46 very generic
title by Alex akor-neb we watch as stars
so what he basically says is with black
you should play the Queens gambit
declined and I mentioned this book
formed one particular reason it is
actually quite similar to a book in his
choice of lines it's quite similar to a
book that I had to last year in my
revenues by Bandit oldest is the default
defy of classical repertoire and what
corner he is doing is he recommends a
similar set of lines but there are some
things that sorry that was close close
to a big sneeze iam and he recommends a
similar set of lines but with some
twists and I think the twists are
interesting so um if you are interested
in a black repertoire with d45 that can
be an interesting book I have not yet
studied it in a lot of detail because
the book is we are quite new
online on my desk insane so what are
things interesting is the following he
covers with black he colors these
classical lines and if white plays in
this way he plays the same system with
my bt7 as the tildes does it's it's it's
what is currently in fashion
however there are some differences in
other lines and this is mostly here in
the exchange variation the until
discovers the most natural movie 65 but
corn F goes 95 which gives gives an
entirely different type of position that
is more yeah it is rather transposition
of will offer transpose after you before
takes takes into a semi tolerable c5
which is totally different and it is an
interesting line to play because I think
white players would have relatively
little clue what to do it they don't get
this often so it's an interesting line I
mean it's a matter of taste s as always
but I think it's interesting to cover
that and the most interesting choice
however in the book is that they have it
basically has two two paths one is the
let's say conventional Queen's Gambit
and then he has an offbeat part and the
offbeat part is interesting where he
covers 93 and now the news a six which
looks odd yeah
really odd but a six yeah is actually
quite an interesting law and has been
played by many strong players and even
by yeah modern-day stars like manga
scars and a six we had moved black
basically
intends to capture and then be ready to
play b5 so what has to think about this
if the capture is a problem or not for
example if white plays a still move
black might take and try to keep the
pawn the same idea is also played here
at f3 a6 that dates back to a Laconia
1920s
and this is actually surprisingly
interesting yeah
black yes again this idea to take at the
right moment and it can lead to
completely unexplored variations or
variations that are only starting to
develop for example 93 9 f6 now if white
takes on d5 that's an interesting form
of exchange variation where white is
committed to 93 or early on that is not
ideal and black even has totally new
setups here with Bishop e6 96 at times
it's really quite fascinating that this
is a newly developed way of playing that
is not so much known in fact what corner
of GTA he kind of yeah he was some just
quicker than me because I was thinking
of presenting such repertoire at one
point and he he yeah he also called the
strength with early a sixes
that can be interesting for black so I
think it's a very interesting topic I
have not really looked through the book
in much detail so I cannot really tell
you okay this is fantastically done or
whatever
I think the selection and the topic is
really interesting so I wanted to
mention the book and point you to this
interesting way of playing so I'm the
final strictly opening book that I'm
going to cover is this one the full you
can put this back it's called the full
English opening by
castor has a cousin Alton is a feeder
master from Denmark and he has written
really lots of books but now it's got
20-something books I think wooden and
yeah this is a book that you rarely see
nowadays it's a type of book that you
rarely see nowadays it's about an
opening in this case of course the
English opening with one c4 and it is
not a repertoire book but rather shows
yeah everything that there is to a
certain depth it's not super deep
obviously the book has 450 pages about
yeah 460 so when you cannot show
everything
yeah then there is then you would have
one thousand two thousand page book it's
just information explosion nowadays but
how does it I think it does a good job
of basically condensing that to the to
the fundamentals and minutes called
mastering the fundamentals to the
fundamentals of the opening so if you
are interested in the English opening
you will get information about basically
everything to a certain level of depth
so it's not a repertoire book that will
only show you a suggestion what to play
but rather everything everything a
little bit and if you're interested in
the English I think it's a very good
book to start with because you get a lot
of information already to begin with and
in a later stage you might want to
specialize using something else but the
Hanson is a very diligent writer and
he's written books on the English before
so it's a very good starting point if
you want to learn about this opening
which is very versatile and therefore
tough to cover in a single volume book
so I think you did a good job there with
this one okay that is about 1 C form so
I've got
more opening book and this is their the
only book in the whole review that I
really think you should not buy I mean
I'm not saying buy everything that I
recommend I'm just saying okay these
books are I think they they are either
good like my opinion or I think they are
fresh and interesting I cannot really
say that I've read them the ones that I
got like a couple of days ago when this
is this is this next book I don't get
simply I don't understand why it was
published and what the point is
okay here it is it's called what is that
called
grand master opening preparation by Yann
illness and I got that book from quality
chess and they usually really have a
high quality and publication but that
book I just don't understand I don't
understand the point of it I mean for
example this book has 270 pages so it
has 130 pages on isolated queen palm
positions out of the Tarrasch the tirage
defends in the Queen's Gambit and
honestly I don't see the relevance I
mean if you want to just know how to
play against this theoretically speaking
it's easy white is better in many lines
and they're not tough to find out but
it's not like you mentioned them even
and then he gets he gives some some some
more of an overview on middle game ideas
and but these games are all brilliant I
mean they are all well known
nothing new about it and I didn't quite
I didn't quite get the point and there
are some really odd chapters I mean
there is there's one chapter that has
just one page and it doesn't it makes no
sense and it's kind of weird it's a
really real and I don't really know any
positive effect that it could get it
could could give you you know so it's
it's very strange in my opinion and they
also do some theoretical information
that is just outdated and I don't know
why it is in the book I have no clue why
you would want to look at some line of
line from the 1970s it's a really good
book there's also very odd chapter about
opening repertoire for women which is
completely what I mean I don't even know
how to how to describe that anyway that
is a really weird look and I don't
really see why you should get it you
will get no particular the great new
opening ideas maybe if you're interested
in some in some history of the tirage
defense yeah then then maybe but it's
not a really super relevant opening so I
don't quite get the book this is the
kind of book that I purchased and five
days later after I've read through most
of it I decided okay I will sell it and
I hope somebody buys it anyway it makes
a little sense to me okay so now
something different let's go for two
empty books and yeah his book that was
actually not published this year but in
its
2013 so it's a couple of years old and
is this one called mastering endgame
strategy by human helps them this is the
book that I had on my shelf and somehow
never used sometimes you get those books
you put them on the shelf I think I care
maybe that is useful and you never use
it I mean using it form for lessons I
mean and this year at one point I saw
that on my shelf let's have a look at
that actually it doesn't make any sense
this book and it does make some sense
actually
and I think it's actually quite well
well written it gets this odd quality of
combining relatively basic concepts in
the ending with them with more advanced
words so for example the azzam chapter
called Luke themes so it's about rooks
and it's he starts and I think this is
nicely chosen he starts with some basic
rook endings that everybody should know
when I come loose in a position and
philidor's defense on the six rank
things like that but rather quickly
develops them into more advanced
concepts and I think it's a pretty nice
ending book that has never really
mentioned and I think it can be an
interesting addition to your to your own
training it's kind of let's say if you
always recommend the 100 end games by de
la vía and for more advanced stuff the
endgame menu by Trotsky this is kind of
in the middle it has a bit of the basics
but also gives more complex example so
it's a good middle-of-the-road
alternative to to those books or simply
something that you can get in addition
if you
more exercise and so on it's a pretty
good book that nobody really ever talks
about and yeah probably because
everybody goes for the endgame menu by
the [ __ ] but it's it's a good one
okay the next one is some I think yeah
very highly recommended it's this one
endgame whoo - oh so magnus carlsen this
book I like a lot have you stood in my
my training sessions lessons quite a bit
and it is about Magnus cards and games
and it's an it is written in coal not in
chronological order so it starts with
the games that he plays played as kids
like 2000 to 2003 when he was 12 or 13
and you already had some very very nice
end games at the time in particular some
of them were very instructive because
the opponents weren't that great yeah he
was playing like regular GMS or amateurs
even sometimes and he was winning very
nice endings down and comedy is a very
prolific author he has done great things
with books on cop off and in child and I
think he does a good job of annotating
causes endings what I think is very nice
here is that he actually focuses on the
endings he doesn't talk much about the
openings in some cases on most cases he
actually starts with the action ending
it doesn't even mention how it's got
them and like the annotations died a lot
it's not overly complicated like they're
not if you if you look at this and get a
good impression I mean you know I don't
know if you can really see it all that
great it
it has quite a bit of text not so many
lines but it focuses I think on the most
important things the things that are
essential for each position I like it a
lot if you want an end game book I mean
that is not about theoretical endings
but practical endings if you want an
ending book and win if you happen to be
a fan of cards nights it's probably even
better but even if you are not a
particular fan of his chess or him as a
person whatever and he has great endgame
skills and the book is fantastic too to
get more into that excellent examples
and I think I like the like the notation
style it's not super complicated it's
very accessible so a good end game book
a book that I also like to mention is
this one that's this one strike like you
did wonder if you can really see that
due to the way the camera operates can
read that
that's a nice book by a few mastered
shots hurt but didn't know that person
see the master from the vs this is a
book it's a very light read this is a
book that is mostly about yeah the the
winning tactics combinations that you
did program flight program that was a
very aggressive attacking player and she
had many many great yeah combinational
winning aggressive play and this is a
very light book in the sense that it
doesn't have that much text or it's
mostly about tactics and I think this is
a good book that you can yeah give it to
junior players to learn tactics from
from for games or from a game let's say
[Music]
yeah then are not completely
disconnected from games that's what I'm
trying to say so not just a diagram but
it shows the full games or the game from
a particular point on where it gets
interesting it's also I think a very
good book to maybe you motivate your
girls if they
I into chess I think Judah can be an
excellent role model and again it's a
very large read it has many diagrams not
so much text as you see here you've got
many diagrams with with the flashy
tactics very nicely shown so it is
possible to read that even if you are
not like the blindfold King yeah you can
is the diagram here are like three or
four moves and then you can can easily
read that so I think it's an access very
accessible book and also quite
entertaining in poker as mentioned she
was a very technical and aggressive
player it's not a super deep tactical
book or anything but I think it's a good
book more more on the light side then
that would be for me fantastic let's say
give it to a junior player especially
two girls I think it could be I think
very inspirational a nice book and that
is mostly a thing for friends of the
players this one it's about from yellow
karana the Challenger to the World
Championship title by Alexandre
convenient convenient I think is an I am
right
oh no he's a grandmaster I'm sorry yeah
and here he has written a book here on
Caruana choosing his most instructive
games again I like the annotation style
it's not super dense but then didn't you
get totally overwhelmed by variations
and I think it's a good game selection
I mean come on I have played many good
games his I think his style of play is
actually quite suitable form for study
because he has a very clean style you
know it's a he he never plays something
unsound or something where you can
they cannot recommend that to people I
mean this is always the problem with
those super creative players like let's
say Joe bagua or report its they play
the stone don't don't try this at home
chess and Khurana obviously I mean he's
an extremely strong player and the chess
is sometimes very difficult or difficult
to understand because of the of the
level that he has but it's so kind of
logical yeah it's not completely
irrational
I think it's nice especially if you're a
fan of the player yeah that I think is
some kind of you're not necessary but
it's it's not it's probably not for
everyone let's say if you're not a fan
of caranas chest it probably doesn't
make not much sense to study it but I
mean I think he's a very strong player
and I think it's slanted players so it
can be a good one to get I see that
video is getting longer than I
originally thought
anyway so in the final book here is
something that I also need to study
myself a little bit more I only got it a
couple of days ago but I wanted to
mention it because it's something that I
feel is very useful to look at in
general and it is one it's called
practical chess beauty by your heart an
effect I think is an international
master in a regular chess but he's a one
of the young he's more known actually
for his achievements in chess
composition he has composed chess
studies for quite a long time now it is
a grandmaster and one of them I think
most prolific just composers of today
this book is about studies in game
studies and we're talking about 450
pages what I think is really great at he
some very good at selecting positions
showing and showing them in a way that
is actually somewhat more accessible
than it is often if you sometimes you
have chest studies that say in chess
magazines and they are really
complicated they're tough to stand they
mentioned some motifs that you don't
know and this is kind of accessible for
a normal player that say I look through
it not in a very not very detailed so I
cannot really call this in-depth review
but I know there I know the the author I
know that he's great at these things
I've read articles and he that he wrote
and listened to interview and so on it's
a really great way of I think getting
into into studies and it's a fantastic
way actually of training if you want to
prove your endgame calculation good end
game studies can be fantastic for that
so this is something that yeah is in all
likelihood a fantastic book but I have
not yet gets into a very very close
ready to that so I cannot yeah show you
like positions and then I find very
remarkable also because it's very fresh
again in my in my library but I would be
very surprised that isn't a great book
so I hope you enjoyed this all your
books it's almost 46 minutes in and yeah
maybe you find some recommendation in
there that you like that you could think
about purchasing yeah this will be one
of the final videos for this year I
guess I hope you are already good year
2018 and you will all get to have a good
start for 2019 thanks a lot for watching